[Music]
[Applause]
gofer repeat here and especially I want
to to acknowledge the people who are not
here physically would have been trying
to figure out different time zones I
know it especially you to push out of
our mind who was here with us in spirit
last year and it's past midnight in the
Arabah and she filled up watching hustle
thank you
which I know my friends in Mexico
working of their their launch site to
turn into a YouTube streams I'm really
grateful for that I think the one
universal truths that I learned in media
studies the last couple of years either
after the first few seconds of the video
people just watching don't have us all a
favor and I'll just give you the too
long didn't read Christian armies of
these projects which is if you find
yourself making decisions of our online
privacy of youth which is basically a
position you can expect to be a and if
you're a programmer if you're a designer
you can have a new social initiative
that is basically not gated and
requiring an ID of the entrance or you
find yourself in a position where you're
giving kids are youth advice on their
own privacy you would like to phone your
heart and will probably try their very
best to be sensible and that's really
great but you should know that your
advice our I agree we will be very
loaded with ideas that are actually
coming
their entire system of progressive
beliefs at well-meaning adults who will
sometimes give you advice that basically
United civility of learning subjects of
rice today we'd be knighted sometimes
the possibility of agency we will trip
us talking about online risk in ways
that are either fragrant people that
know everything about on their race
which is kind of even possible and also
can bring us people who are just walking
most importantly in my opinion as a
different talk about aliveness give you
we are committed to awful idea
not only that victims should be blamed
victims for example sixteen cells but
that their individual positions matter
more than the decisions of the people
around them sort of benign sense of
collective responsibility you probably
think that you know this actually person
means with you and we never never being
complete privacy that way my
conditionings but despite our very best
conditions because we're in my class is
misogynistic easiest system that she
agrees on everything including you
online privacy that's basically just the
case devil is in the details and the
point of this presentation is to explain
how it is the narratives about you
online privacy show the very very worst
of us
but also on hopeful note how
organization
are currently living all over the
continent to fix this program and that's
the core of metal today so how do my
life who were review informal and
context from all these critical thinking
on privacy there were two ways
indicators and localize where to think
about predict and engage with and
circulate and yes about online privacy
in youth the findings I summarize today
are the result of 18 interviews that I
carried out with practitioners from over
the continents from Canada to Argentina
in 12 countries as well as a community
channel researcher of their own works
and the works of other organizations
I've been interviewed basically like
attending from price seeking proposals
to classroom materials and contain
videos like you know feels expands in
the on the shoulders of that intimate
room have to experience a new name I
actually seeing in this room today and
so I try to put the findings in my knees
in conversations with academic
literature and even privacy around
studies and also on I wasn't development
of visual southern trek through this
brush in his presentation today I want
to start by and religion that
research has nothing to do with me just
being clever and thinking that vice
thought Rick Hardy not real enough I
would have something to say that will
change anything in the world I think
that there are many like 34 mimicking
disperses so something the short version
of what them achieve basically mine when
I arrived in compartment in your face it
was after a decade of volunteering and
working as a technology capacity builder
these are the so called circuit breakers
it's a my beliefs bridge to me meant
that doesn't inspire the use of this
term for the sake of time I will not go
log into it but what I want to say is
rather important part of this concept of
technological capacity building which by
the way is a term I have up there for my
friend Eric Slater who will also be
watching this video later is that we get
to promote conversations in different
parts of civil society that otherwise
would not be happening and so we we have
is a privileged access to see the
relationship between technology and
society from different types of our
conditions and in my case it was two
different spaces the space of digital
rights with the focusing openness
movement spirit technology and also the
only other site through my work with
UNICEF I ever a sense of what work if
the human rights field who would play in
a world where collaboration
gets firmer having and put as an empty
promise in grant proposals and then keep
very important to say that
in my experience we're not really they
were not just not incorporating big work
through a very strong tensions between
them in fine for me this much of that
best captures the extensions comes from
a goal state that if you can incarnate
square which is one of the biggest
internet digital rights and again most
of it in pictures
dozens of sessions from also called
stakeholder groups group economy
industry technical community whatever
that means
since I may be the biggest players in
the field of youth and media there and
still are the people rights
organizations they each one exhibitions
on youth rights people Jews and
childhood pictures of my decisions and
then the wrestling decisions of the more
traditional freedom of expression and
the internet issues
I already thinking it as the Internet
Society go in close repeat and I went to
all positions of both teams and feel
very alone even doing so it didn't
really find a very high and interesting
where have you bring us a bottle to both
sides of this kind now and it will
discover anything new in the area with
others people who do your research and
media studies describe you serve under
mystic thing in between uses online and
interaction how evening into the
collaboration between both and when they
feel fear organizational evidence
kind of like Oh what will not sit down
in order for these people to be able to
make sense
I want that people activity for my
research might have a niche programs and
plywood sheets research management in
Brazil sheer comedic to limits of
distinction very eloquently
so according her very a few years ago
when were speaking about physical rights
and the role most in society
organizations Wilson defend free speech
or privacy way it wasn't if you would
not understand the other side of the
table
police worrying about chopper and so on
website the police side persecution of
cranks online and then the other side
looks like you have a reputation saying
that this was not sorry that you should
be compared with benefits that the
internet was bringing so going for champ
rights within a way to bring over a
chair and policies of a minute is was a
major if my internet being authoritarian
for the sake of youth and so what are
the implications were NGO work for the
market even for basic Internet
infrastructure if there are youth under
active adults get framed as either or
who benefits most producers are going to
criminal now this presentation is taking
place at a time when the authoritarian
side of maintaining he's very much part
of public discourse in the US I think
especially since the discussions are
very public discussions on the role of
social media and Internet companies on
the literal of God since that are
charged Victoria's here initially
weakly settles that if they each group
otakus very impeachment with the
outreach basically bringing us to be
very nice discussion and says the FASTA
bills and cambridge alicia very mind
that the context that describing is a
legacy of the money
meconium is ready delivers another
context context before Edward Snowden's
revelations that can burn out served
very widespread very deep surveillance
and Sukie corporate cooperation that can
no longer be ignored I hope you that you
know number thief's division existed
before it was cool to talk about how
they power parity on the Internet beef
but rather than present
run long enough for institutional status
from funding too much funding
relationships to narrow his division as
an gain deeper into distinction
government at stake I in my opinion are
populated to our visions of childhood
youth and technology many of which we
can be point indictments through media
analysis going and acquired from her
hands which is emotional day for a
decision that supports I use by using
harm reduction approach is going to be
illustrative corner there's a tendency
to be both dismissive and alert when it
comes to use of technology some of their
victims of technologies but we also have
the given that they are using
too much either they are sunny and
confident and we should work with them
and trust them and we are relative to
them or there is not under equity there
is default dichotomy of not trusting men
thinking of their understanding of
privacy is what else decrying the
recruiters nature of taking their advice
if national I think that before on my
nation gay I'm providing youth online
safety campaigns especially when they
are useful works but very sexual and
reproductive rights distress think
before you six ten weeks another sixth
which is the message that in my opinion
is very reminiscent of officially
discourse in sexual education and also
happen to be the title of a series of
give us priority Mexico by public
institutions corporations like Google
Mexico and as punish and do now many
different cells have more nuanced more
youth-friendly privacy messages I
actually be more progressive in this but
the general are bringing I said early
today a very nice free responsive
society organizations New Mexico again
on the other side points of arguing that
this training took was very much swing
rewarding on the victim
none of the person violating their
consent in recommending the United
States are favorable and research on
rural of lessons and new migration
reminds us that this year's for safety
have long accompany females involvement
in your society and they contain
persist for young women on social media
saying studies where parties worrying
more for the safety of their voters then
for your sons trainings like this in my
opinion support a narrative of kids
especially girls spending too much time
online sending too many pictures of
themselves on the one hand and not
understanding the consequences of their
acts on the other now I think that there
is something positive to say about this
campaign which is that at least it
appeals to you know the idea of thinking
before setting because it concedes that
you actually have a choice ultimately
and you know the best bet was in
persuading them to making a different
choice not you know to force them by a
permanently monitoring them you know
surviving there if I only activity and
turn into take bacterial versions and
they break the rules which as weird as
it sounds is not something that can be
taken for granted and visionary
parenting workers school posts reviewing
you know the latest spy work to use on
your kids these accounts meaning to your
social media accounts and all sorts of
like we're going to enact particle
surveillance right so their parents will
be trying to keep their kids in because
I believe that this comes out of a good
place of trying to protect their kids
we basically decide what to take any
form of privacy away from them I guess
in their mind you try not to be joseline
under any circumstances and so like I
notice the efforts of this diet have two
layers to them
according to one of the interviews music
is laughable
and according to a brass color and some
there's something about privacy but
easier that's one event that is eternity
or cheated by using research on human
privacy to sort of be there equipped
with an institution to navigate the
discussion and personal better
protection that is happening in between
the conference right now says that the
logic of on any protection principles is
more or less the principles of all
external knowledge of their system
threats and best practices I've given to
control realizing defined limited
situations and get to not only remember
points beauty and eating from our
experience position to exert control
over others fascinating place that one
is a work for the press and the
expiration seems lovable on your hand
mixtape just for the sake of argument
that we could understand actually all
the threats and all the best practices
even then privacy scholar Daniel solo
discovered even default the economy of
privacy versus security among Internet
that more surveillance will be more
secure life rarely move
I really thought the citrix course I
offered them to overlook the fact that
he's so excited trading squares where
he's simply impossible for you to win
you know our Fortran C could be deemed
this word the security is only related
to the use of technology and can use
these cushions feeds into other areas
people with development service culture
or abundance and oppression and because
technology capacity builders or media
makers or researchers we really commit
to invest ourselves into these marketing
impressions then we need to engage in
initiatives where you are - the subjects
with specific developmental needs
yes but also with agency we don't need
to take choices away from them we
initiatives with you are not just
potential citizens in the future but
subjects of rice today and those rights
are direct not just stay feet Peralta
privacy essential and reproductive
health and we need to work for
exhibition where technology regulation
practices are like both with youth in
that ultra days especially the rights of
those marginalized adults who are
currently on their service surveillance
because of our structure that has
important to place for the sake of
protecting use so if you take this to
our gift if we're interested in doing
music online directly we have a
challenge achieve starting through all
these a few words of work to find
evidence or inspiration enough we have
looked spoke Midway never post your
stuff but bodies with the stranger
danger advisor 2018 when they can miss
make
of these education initiatives through
the lives of the energies of
surveillance where each person animals
that are Indian the air here is a risk
and appropriateness that gives suspicion
on the social practices of youth where
we envision worldwide and especially in
the Americas which is where a region of
interest are working already on this job
especially invites an America where
youth leadership comes from new
organizations and work on these subjects
new campaigns and I've tried to to reach
this traditional but now if you tell you
what the motivation center of attention
is underlying his birthday they have a
great sort of told you about the
tensions of payments over tonight so I
would like to now move on to the central
characteristics of their work the first
point I want to make is that the frame
is orientation see people use privacy in
the names of American continent
countries you will actually not find any
of them that is because they don't
self-identify as organizations for
community I mean you have to try Google
you have the data these are the things
that they cooled air won't work so these
are basically it's uh pretty cool thing
that there is no user privacy where it's
taking place especially in Latin America
and that we need to bring European
taxation to do it you are wrong of
course it exists because some cold-ass
of what you and I do call them now who
needs like the real characteristics of
their work the first one that's
throughout West cookie-san now for my
work with with Sasha in the design
studio and essentially project I know
that for a DC what are you staring at
Victor turn around the laws and a right
you know cools our project for DC
vibrations because of its over it or
because reefs most are explicit you
should not give your feedback
instruction what I think that give
participation especially is more
complicated than that so what happened
to my two organizations among the seven
the 18 that I interviewed that do
contain work with youth one of them is
far better than she's a brilliant young
organization mentoring new
communications leg and communications
professionals and used to work for
they're gonna and say to do meaningful
work through an NGO Sarah they cooperate
with academics like your neighbor I'll
see you at pardoning the
agenda forward in use on the media
studies in Girija and quote again the
director of this organization through
sarcasm you we need to go work rather
than just great and about centric view
of the responsible use safety and
privacy in authority contains that don't
manage to to bridge the gap the scholars
dating a boy barely married have pointed
out as the perception gap between what
we think are these experiences prayers
what you actually perceive their
experience of privacy to be if we don't
manage to reach it we don't really have
a chance to to do effective remaining
and one way to bridge it is through
co.design now what does for example buy
breakfast for finally valid this is
basically designed workshops with
teenagers where they start about talking
about media practices identifying things
they find problematic and things like
ooh and working together on the same
solutions even if it's just speculative
solutions to fix the problems they find
this kind of work led to a campaign that
was not produced by adults would bind
you on a different think of what
universe has been basically to promote
and not even suspect police is also
present in the work of the quality
project in university also I guess
research
the city's privacy and other finally
policies through the lives of equality
and really through the lives of
inequality they also did a quote
exciting project but they want to speak
about them on another point which is
institutional youth involvement they
were the only organization
I interviewed that actually had a humid
fiery board and that actually presents a
very beautiful rationale behind it which
is that you need another program one
person can represent many and they made
especially in three generational debate
each other learning tool working with
the floor you eat not only the way back
organizations are frankly is fun isn't
the only way that these organizations
practice what they preach here - keep an
orientation and also interviewing Canada
and their work in crazy it sparked
through their sexual education program
but they also have very strong
institutional arrangement in terms of
confidentiality practices and press
ability to defend youths rates privacy
and that is because new tonight
they usually work with you contact with
the judicial system and underlining
their own policies whether a
confidentiality with a tiebreaker risk
rather than serving them another
characteristic of work being done to
defend you phrase basically adversity -
media services in live to them and so I
think that people who work in the field
of even being us all are familiar with
the work of an employer who has seen
very famous of her deputies for her
since you've all and it really you know
part of it and he was reading about
youth and online safety
she passed whole over the academic
chance that our fishing our trains she
understand incorporate in school equals
expense weekly whenever she says that
she's found a window of opportunity I
think Eastern for us to show and listen
and then we don't over tunity that she
under the US was an intern at health
life she explains before she set out to
do that the u.s. in her have an example
which may be been established length of
communication that functions as an
intermediary layer that helps users both
on the ground and then keep all for
providing the Internet services so HS
get help on respective companies
declaration companies moderation piece
get pre-screening context in different
different equal with flabulous
discussing earlier in the day and so the
penguin 100 distillation is one of the
main worlds of addressing online
harassment I think that I can hopefully
really provides a service with a new
perspective the
our solutions I think that are gonna
love about the way under strikes you're
wearing a cuff link
is that a little the times features will
cook in sort of saying you know we have
a problem or someone posted it on
Instagram and so you know the content
actually needs to be reported on the
actress and so there's a part of the
process where they just send the
features back to the kids at school to
figure out how exactly you report and
pulsating rent a security some way of
supporting the local leadership in the
school sort of the key in the end the
one training the future and that takes
me to different transition that is also
supporting local leadership moving the
position and that I think a lot of a
part because of the work well people
have any sense if that an ordinary
sitting in this room today the other
foundation since they things to go has
one mean one of the key players in the
beautiful rights basically the different
years they're learning initiative has
put out some of the most interesting why
would a trustee curricula but interview
will check something works for Casilla
learning so in a very short about that
as a community that's very distributed
geographically the bushes will support
local leadership through some EMS alone
are moving on Thursday and I think
because of the work of people a - that
crew who have really pushed a global
organization through the world locally
then became talk about how look a local
support comes first
when working on using privacy which make
me to another point was company many of
their annotations but I one thing that
to accepted by the work of the equal
rights organization teams by the right
famous in derision for their super
successful country surveillance contains
they have worked really actually be
kinda traditional American so physical
rights defense focused even focus on
what surveillance means for trans people
for women journalists and novels of her
youth I am quitting session on this
again more anything is by a convenient
the way that most marginalized people
are surveil the Google very of lots of
the workings of the system whatever the
creative ways that people are assisting
the servants and it is no surprise that
you of their annotations I interviewed a
charter about suing Costa Rica use
inflexible are using interactive
experiences as a way to approach topics
of privacy with you
saliva soup is is a authority that is
currently developing a tabletop game
embrace and instant Brazil has been
extremely successful in reaching youth
through the Americas brother which is a
vehicle
on Facebook where you engage with a
chocolate in a series of audio-visual
materials that humorous and in a
scenario that deals with non-consensual
image sharing or that the so called
revenge porn these are really
interesting takes from what your friend
view that which means but then we
deserve use a language quickly turning
to legal discussion with article 12 in
Mexico to strategic litigation and
reminding me that there is no such thing
as your friendly language in practice
United States which are sort of the
cornerstone of personal that prediction
when you've got a view from the enemies
how can you expect consent I mean you
can't consent what does that tell us
about their role of users or the
investments we're in I guess I am the
only person standing in between you and
white
being Rudy's left of this Ethernet lab
doesn't just focus and other
organizations and just focus on you know
potential implications for you in some
cases and actually look at divisional
outcomes and so even in lucky that
groundbreaking research on how a
non-consensual image sharing was getting
treated by courts in Brazil and how in
turn young women were being experienced
by the system and finally the importance
of a rights based approach and you could
be antidotes to focusing what people
cannot do
he suppose on what are you thinking you
because it's actually the right to do
and that was it for many of their
acquisitions I've mentioned already but
other organizations that haven't yet
mentioned and especially really blew my
mind when I was originally just going to
interview reveals which was the office
of the Privacy Commissioner II gotta go
Canada basically a regulator that it's a
privacy is Airstream with a super
progressive and meticulously crafted
Larry was resistant to the classroom
will be English and French okay that
when you yell at you yes subjects of Rex
today and that what those rights either
a Branson we're gonna love the actual
opinions but I will stop and moved war
move on to Alaska methodological note
which is mighty about what research for
efficacy can mean I think I might need
this excited to publish individual blog
post already changer you understand
diversity media which means that after
each interview I am directly have a post
that I am sent back to the interviewees
they are free to participate in the
editing process and some of them have
actually become co-authors when the
number of edges the
they accepted at the end of the whole
versus I mean cancer has hung out with
the people who are interested because
many of the participants say that the
actual women to meet other people
working on his privacy in rincón well in
addition of these research and other
come is that there were no youth
involved which means that it's another
growing adult presentation for you and
from experimenting this after CMS yuccas
against this project has made me more
committed in reclaiming discourse with
the communities that have been
marginalized shaking it like youth but
also older women next present another
new joint
I want to take my last minute to say
that I'm really grateful to all my
friends in civil society and moment our
cases have extremely easy life and jobs
since you made might be no time to
practice keep thinking the research will
that IRB consent form citing privacy
funds but also have external advisors my
everyone else and enjoy myself and I
kept getting all these interview
requests and I just hated women I gave
people waves interview in to express
knowledge for my orientation again so
I'm really grateful for people who took
the time to do this so man I am
retaining our disciplines that helped me
have guided me since I was a teenager
interest in these topics like grandsanta
or I've been highly subtract so people
are an incredible part of our
communities
HP is beautiful this is immersive media
for eternity
so my running I mean a genetics like
that using social media at California
State University Fresno they're rushing
miss lemon after we take honor and also
you know that some people for my crime
and yokai like Erica's me a lifetime
interact with a Mexico and other French
furniture and I think we're watching
this and I think that they have been
extremely insightful and generous induce
research versus so I think that there
may be a few other easily
I must hear speech made a mystical that
these projects are actually like it
takes a village of my friend I think I
would say but and of these project
especially born in my philosophy school
where I wrote a thesis about human
ethics of mind with my uncle and my
simple was anticipating with my mother
so I think that it's not a name people
sort of being smart on going to grad
school and having always ready yes when
you kids older boy into to make that
happen
and again not taking luxury because I
thought the less person and I think that
all of us we're rewriting our pieces of
their company revision Placidia just
looking at all the documents were
holding classes that we have assumed an
NSYNC have years of changes in two years
it was CMS is a bringing to lady another
new space when my dream
here are many missing like a luxury that
thinks other efforts are making people
wear magazines and that we are very
grateful for and also the work of two
classmates who are not here today but
participating in our conversations will
work Sunday when asked a policeman
tnehews rings together reproductive
rights and technology and when Barney
whose brilliant Egyptian gaining oh yeah
okay what almost makes me want to be a
geek so that I won't even break fee
online as able something I never liked
about academic spaces is that the Q&A
has been framed of the only legitimate
form of interaction so no I would love
your comments runs critiques
I have perhaps a very boring question
but a methodological question by
implementing 218 interviews in 11
countries which is both incredibly
impressive and also a kind of diffuse
approach so I'm wondering how in the
thesis itself you kind of deal with the
international issues and in fact you
know you don't want to come up with a
theory or analysis that applies across
the board to all of these 11 countries
right so how did you approach that and
sorted through magna logically in
retrospect the question was Xavier
nearly the fact that he was 11 countries
in 18 their negatives in how to units in
Java and huge respect of course I would
never do that again
it was very continuous in believing that
you know it's nice enough of a topic to
go interview a whole country Anthony how
do I make sense of it I don't talk much
about the conflicts which again
[Music]
so while on the other hand waters and
things that you could say that are
interesting about we do the regional
dynamics or the things that worse in
order
some name is come on come on I would say
17 of the 18 interviewees was the they
don't really have funding for this they
are all struggling to get funding for
this I think it was only the office of
the mayor and programmatic 20 but keep
churning out educational materials there
so in the usually provinces enrich the
educational system that way most open to
both don't funding that so you would
think that even in the u.s. that would
be much easier but no I think they like
big part of the conversation with Monaco
here the Curie days the result of 20
years or more of research and
understanding the ecosystem and we
needed the piece of service that is
missing and yet funding in for the last
few years have been extremely tired so
funding is a commonality and the
difference I would say is something
really interesting this without a suit
in video setting powers that you know if
not okay context for people in the US
but that'd be like the most developed
country in Central America anyone speak
with someone who's an experienced that
nature is probably sitting at the back
but they're not being very developed
country in Central America and so there
there is a lot of other economic issues
however basic and secure messaging
services like stigma don't work there so
other people try to let's take oh you
know the thing is they're not using all
these securities
and yeah it's broken so you kind of
tension work is the cave of service
exist and it is the keys of this you
know awareness of this but the
infrastructure does not to respond to it
and sewing is something else that is
different is the role of Internet
services and companies like social media
companies in other countries they I can
help blank model where I have legs like
an intermediary between Facebook and the
school only works in the US where there
is such thing as cooperation between all
those encoders when I am clearly been
collective doing essentially the same
work in your way I didn't even know that
it was a possibility to work with
Facebook directly I didn't know this
collation of reports was the thing and
so there's your like a huge
I think we will in fact see many
organizations and I have already seen
our magazine is coming out with its
press releases on their topic but
something that we need to remember is of
the u.s. electoral context and the
relationship between the snake oil 7
company which is Cambridge in America in
the very specific role of the US is not
something that looks the same in other
countries and so I am very worried when
I see premiums like big memes or
Cambridge analogy I kept throwing to the
legendary digital rights peace course
where democracies work differently and
where the manipulation machines work
differently so I feel that I mean
there's arguments here right but what
they can use a separate of bringing to
discuss looks like with media easier if
it's just Thomas raining and see if it's
like a problematic written here how can
we expect it to work seamlessly you guys
an American I think it's kind of the
same with the Cambridge analytical
Fiasco and other experience but I do
think that I mean pragmatically I think
it's better to have more noise even if
some of the nuances looks like I have
all you were saying you know with this
Cambridge analytical thing you should
shut this book yeah shut it down
I am happy to see that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]